hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the oslo esports cup where we are
going to cover the first game of the
match pragananda versus eric hansen now
prague has been having an excellent
tournament he started the first three
days with uh absolute victories then he
ran into magnus cross and then he lost
all three games they played and now we
are in round five so uh we'll probably
be able to bounce back or will eric have
a a say in this it's a really a
devastating attack you are going to
enjoy this game and uh once again you
will see uh
how how well these young players are
able to prepare for a game against
anyone even though
you're playing four games every day uh
against a different opponent and still
you are able to
to prepare so well so uh prague has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have knight to f6 c for g6 knight to c3
and we transpose into the uh gruntful
defense eric plays d5 we have c captures
knight captures uh and now e4
challenging the knight here we have
knight captures b captures and bishop to
g7 so this is very standard stuff we've
seen this many many times and now uh you
are going to play something like a
knight to f3 or rook to b1 or one of the
many many popular moves here but the
progress uh queen to a4
is not extremely rare but it is much
rarer than the other continuations and
especially since eric plays c6 here this
is even rarer so this is obviously
progress uh some uh something that
prague prepared uh specifically for eric
here we have knight to f3 castles and
now bishop to e2 and here after b5
challenging the queen uh we are still in
the game that uh eric hansen already
played with the black pieces last year
against arsene esterov that he lost uh
but now okay the queen can be retreated
to b3 or c2 or even d1 pro plays queen
to a3 and now we shift from that game uh
and now i believe that uh it it it is
possible that eric is in a completely
new territory however the position is
still a known one knight to d7 was
played castles and now rook to e8 and it
is only now as of movie 11 that we have
a completely new game
so let's see how they continue with
bishop to g5 you can see that there's
some uh pressure here on the e7 pawn
also you can to just advance it since
the queen is on the eighth uh knights to
b6 by eric now preparing to develop the
light square bishop also at some point
you will start pushing that a pawn rook
8 to d1 and now queen to d6 offering a
queen trade while developing so prague
of course declines this uh he he does
control more space at the moment queen
to c1 and now bishop to e6 going after
this a2 pawn uh with bishop to f4
attacking the queen queen to d8 and not
knight to e5 and here what do you do do
you just capture the pawn do you maybe
first trade the bishop uh for not uh
bishop for night and then captured upon
uh if you go for something like this
okay now you can let's say capture the
pawn but after something like f4
white's uh center is just beautiful and
f5 is coming and even though you can
play f6 and kind of trap
white's dark square dash upon e5 we can
still continue the attack f5 for example
captures captures and as it's a rapid
game white would have um uh all the
attack here the queen can come to h6 the
rook controls the f5 you can capture on
h7 the bishop can come to h5 so even
though it's fine for black to play this
for a rapid game maybe it would be uh
gambling a little bit too much so there
it goes queen to c8 first uh he guards
the c6 pawn that was hanging and now we
have queen to c2 at developing the queen
again guarding the a2 pawn with f6
removing the knight from this powerful
e5 square knights to d3 and now bishop
back to f7 so at some point you are
hoping to advance this pawn
at the e6 or e5 depending on what's
possible uh but uh prague says uh most
certainly not to e5 he plays e5 himself
and now we have knight to a4 preparing
to further push the pawns um yeah and
put constant pressure on this c3 pawn uh
but now just rook after e1 we have a5
eric pushes on the queen side now comes
the bishop to g3 we have queen to e6 now
putting more pressure on this a2 pawn
and prague defends it with rook to d2
and here eric plays a g5 now this is a
very bold move and maybe a simpler
solution would be just the capture on a2
it looks like a silly move because of
course white is guarding the a2 square
twice but it kind of does work captures
captures captures and captures now we're
going to play captures attack the rook
and the bishop here and after the rook
moves anywhere really we're just going
to capture the bishop here after rook
capture so you're going to get this
position where yes prague is up
our piece but we have two connected pass
pawns on the queen side we can nicely
put the rook on v8 to support the pawns
the bishop could also support the pawns
via the long diagonal so uh definitely
something to consider but okay g5 was
played in the game we have bishop to f1
now the queen here is being x-rayed so
now of course it's very
unpleasant to have it there queen to d5
is played and now pawn to h4 g5 is now a
target and the prague wants to open up
the king side to start an attack against
the black king we have h6 h capture sun
g5h captures and now queen to c1 uh
putting more pressure on on black's king
side so if black ever captures then the
g5 pawn becomes very very weak so bishop
to g6 and now uh f4 uh we open up the
position here and now it's a very hard
to uh to keep the position closed if you
play something like g5 then f5 is coming
and that's very very unpleasant now you
kind of have to capture this otherwise
you're just allowing knight to f4 for
free so for example captures knight to
f4 attacks the queen queen will move
somewhere then we're gonna play e6 and
uh black's position is just so ugly
no one would willingly play this so here
we have bishop the h6 by eric f captures
on g5 f captures on g5 and okay now you
get this position where a black sort of
defended but there is one move that wins
the game completely for prague so feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for prague
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
completely paralyzing idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course pawn to e6 after this
move there is really nothing black can
do uh there is no way to get your pieces
into the game the rooks enter the game
uh the e5 square now becomes available
for the white knight and everything just
falls apart for black
as you'll see so congratulations to
everyone who spotted this positional
idea uh here rook the fate was played by
eric and now comes knight the e5 sort of
saying okay you can capture on e6 but
even if you go for this we can just play
knight captures on g6 queen captures and
now bishop d3 attack the queen and after
the queen moves somewhere now we're just
going to pile up on this pawn here rook
d2 go after the pawn after the pawn is
defended some like rook e6 and as we've
said there's really nothing for uh for
black
uh to play here so instead after the
knight to the e5 bishop to f5 was played
and now comes knight to f7 going after
the h6 bishop here uh rook captures on
f7 eric decides to give a little uh
something uh material to
stop the attack but now not even e
captures on f6 prague plays the absolute
strongest pawn to c4 he wants to open up
this diagonal for his bishop and now
there is nothing for black to do here uh
of course if the pawn is captured we're
just gonna play captures on f7 and it
seems like you can defend queen captures
the bishop captures here you have e6 but
not just rook f2 and now again you uh
really don't have uh all that much the
other rook is coming to f2 we're gonna
put more pressure on the bishop you just
can't hold this or or even better you
could play rook to f2 uh and now after
the rook defends this would rook to e8
you can play rook e5 this could be even
stronger now just with the simple threat
of rook captures there's no way to parry
this if king h7 we're going to play
rookie captures on f5 and of course
there's nothing black can do here you're
going to have to give up the queen
but it is definitely not enough to keep
playing this we can play queen c2 attack
the knight attack the f5 pawn we still
have the bishop pair so there's just no
playing this another thing after
progress c4 you could move the queen
back queen to d8 but this is also not
gonna work we're just gonna capture the
rook and play rook f2 and that's it you
you simply can't play this if e6 you can
even play the
uh the slap in the face move rook
captures on e6 and after king captures
queen e3 and again everything falls
apart for black let's say king f6 queen
e5 check and now you're just gonna check
me that the black king king f7 queen
captures here king j8 queen f7 and after
you go here bishop the h bishop to e5
check once black gives up all of his
pieces then it will be checkmate so
instead after uh c4 eric decided okay it
seems like i don't have any you know
decent moves here i'm going to play
queen captures on e6 and give up my
queen for rook and try to create some
counter play here but now just rook
captures on e6 bishop characters and c
captures on b5 now saying that uh well
if you capture then i'm just going to
play queen c6 attack this bishop if this
bishop moves then this bishop is
attacked also your rook on a8 is hanging
so absolutely everything is hanging here
this would be uh i mean it's already
resignable but of course we're gonna
play a few more moves a g4 uh attacking
the rook and the queen here but now just
queen captures on c6 it's pretty much
the same idea everything is hanging here
bishop to e3 check in the now i probably
just played bishop to f2 andy was in
this position on move 36 that eric
hanson resigned the game
as there is nothing more uh to be done
here uh what do you even play here once
you capture the rook here we're gonna
capture you we you can even capture the
bishop you don't even have to capture
the rook uh the position is just uh so
bad for black that there is no uh
playing this you can't i mean
you can capture on g4 you still have the
bishop fair black's pieces are scattered
all over the board the black king is
completely wide open we can easily
connect a few moves also bishop to c4 is
coming that's i mean
resigns on the spot so eric of course
doesn't wait for any of this after
bishop to eat f2 he resigns and a
brilliant victory for prague in round
one of their encounter uh game two ended
in a draw and again in game three prague
with the white pieces achieved the
victory so again he defeated eric much
like he did everyone in rounds one two
and three so uh prague has a spectacular
tournament it's that one uh one match
against magnus carlsen that puts a bit
of a stain on it but still if we check
out the standings after five rounds here
we have it from the from 24
round five standings of the also esports
cup prague is leading with a score of 12
points followed by magnus with nine yang
[ __ ] of duda and jordan palm forest with
eight points liam lay with seven
anishigiri with six shakira mamdara with
five and eric hansen with three points
so two more rounds to go uh can probably
take it all the way uh or will someone
else be able to catch him uh we'll see
what happens but this is a brilliant
chess and absolutely uh fantastic to
watch uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it always uh uh thank
you for recommending me such a such a
wonderful uh games with great motives uh
i would like to thank fred ackerman
joseph um verasuria uh robert taratone
always cluster hoover and michael
mcconnell for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world but basically
we will cover this event
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day